What do you know about the multiverse
we should tell him the truth
welcome back
everyone this is my doctor strange 2 superior
iron man video i've gotten a lot of requests
since the trailer came out to talk about him
specifically this other version of iron man who
is not robert downey jr being one of the more
interesting illuminati characters from this
multiverse team if you're new to the channel
i'm doing a giveaway for that new spider-man no
way home blu-ray that they just announced with
a whole bunch of tobey maguire andrew garfield
bonus features all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and post all your superior iron
man theories in the comments but in the trailer
you see this version of baron mordo working with
the multiverse illuminati team apologize to our
mcu doctor strange then seemingly haul him to
wherever their bases and put him in these cells
this could be mcu baron mordo but i think it's
a version of baron mordo from the multiverse who
became sorcerer supreme in his universe and he's
replacing doctor strange on the classic roster
most of the roster is pretty close to the original
comic book roster but with multiverse versions
there are a couple differences though that i'll
point out is that your voice in the doctor strange
trailer can you comment on that at all who's dr
strange but you can actually see doctor strange
in these special cells america chavez is in one
of the other cells like the cuffs that they put
them in look like iron man's technology but from
this other iron man variant you see that christine
palmer variant and all the other people in white
lab coats running around but then doctor strange
gets hauled to face the illuminati council
by these ultron robots and they're meant to
belong to this iron man variant in the movie
that we're calling superior iron man right now
they've got ultron vibes about them but a way more
polished version of that like less hardcore but
still very very hardcore the design language
seems just much more like iron man's armor
they come from a universe where their version of
iron man that we're just calling superior iron
man because of the shinier vibe of the suits of
armor seems like he was successfully able to avert
the disaster that was avengers age of ultron
with ultron just going crazy in their universe
their version of iron man was just a little more
hardcore than mcu iron man but was able to use his
technology to create a version of ultron that did
not go off the rails spectacularly like he did in
the mcu and these robots are just the evolution of
that technology the evolution of the iron legion
that we saw but with more infinity stone upgrades
like ultron was an infinity stone upgrade to
jarvis in the iron legion the whole idea during
avengers age of ultron at the beginning of that
movie is that we saw iron man it basically created
the iron legion to function as sort of like mini
versions of himself with ai programming controlled
by jarvis and himself in function with a certain
level of autonomy but for the most part they
were just meant to function like low-level
copies of iron man himself like he wasn't about to
clone himself but he has all these suits of armor
so what if he could automate those and they could
function almost as good as a version of himself
controlled by ai but then the base consciousness
of the mind stone perverted them and upgraded the
system way beyond what iron man intended so that
was when ultron was born his consciousness was
basically like the consciousness of the mind stone
infinity stone mixed with iron man's programming
and tech imagine in superior iron man's alternate
universe that twist with ultron never happened or
when it was happening he was somehow able to stop
that from going off the rails so his ultron never
goes crazy and superior iron man is able to use
the infinity stones to safely upgrade all of his
tech to hyper tech levels so that's why they
kind of look like ultron robots but with way
softer edges like the eyes are wider they look way
less evil but still very very hardcore and even
though there's been lots of speculation about this
figure here people wondering if it's a version of
superior iron man or somebody else because the
low quality of the youtube trailer footage is
kind of blurry there's no 4k clean version to
zoom in and hands on people seeing weird things
in the edges of this character's face i talked
about this in my last doctor strange video too
it's the same person who's fighting the scarlet
witch variant who's got the oil or the fluid
from those superior iron man ultron bots all over
her like in this scene here when she looks like
she's gonna go ham on everybody she's covered
in the metaphorical blood of all these ultron
robots which she's probably just destroyed and
the person that she's fighting here all lit up
with the blue orange energy is a captain marvel
variant who is maria rambo from another universe
because her power signature looks exactly like
captain marvel's in superior iron man even though
his armor would look way different way more
hardcore than mcu iron man's armor it wouldn't
have the same power signature as captain marvel
even in the comics when superior iron man was
fighting people in his armor his power signature
didn't look anything like this right now as
you probably suspected marvel is holding back on
revealing who's actually playing the superior iron
man character and what his armor looks like mostly
because patrick stewart's professor x was meant
to be the big wtf x-men reveal that they wanted
everybody freaking out about in the last trailer
you thought i was asleep didn't you
acting they don't want to give every single thing
away in the first big trailer and when we call him
superior iron man it means something a little
different in the comics than it does in the mcu
right now remember to the loki series they had
this whole thing about who the superior loki was
amongst all the variants in the mcu context
it was meant to denote the best version of
loki like each version here thinks that they
are superior to the other versions around them
personally my pick for superior loki was alligator
loki cannot wait to see him come back during
season 2 maybe some frog thor again too really
big fan of the animal versions of characters
superior iron man in the comics was a version of
the character who had given into his darkest vices
way more egotistical way edgier he actually
thought of himself as a real god amongst men
big man in a suit of armor take that off what
are you genius billionaire playboy philanthropist
he was created when the x-men avengers access
event happened and this will sound familiar it
was another big scarlet witch event scarlet witch
winds up inverting everyone's alignment inside the
616 universe so all the villains become these
morally upstanding heroes and all the regular
heroes like the avengers iron man all kind of
become evil so comic book superior iron man was
like what if iron man but evil his super shiny
looking new armor was called the endo sim armor
it looks kind of like a symbiote because it was
literally like the fusion of symbiote biology and
his technology he creates this highly addictive
version of the extremists that he circulates to
the entire world so that regular people can use it
but they get hooked on it and it starts upgrading
regular people to the level of olympic athletes
so like paraplegics are now almost as strong as
captain america but then once everyone gets
hooked he starts charging everyone money for
the service or he'll turn off their upgrades so
he's sort of like the drug dealer version of iron
man like the first hits free all this amazing
technology that will make you this super person
but if you want to keep it it's going to cost you
the version of superior iron man that it seems
like they have in doctor strange 2 i think will
be a little bit different though but generally
the same vibe as comic book superior iron man like
what if during the infinity saga movies mcu iron
man had made way more hardcore choices that won
them the worst that they thought way faster and
prevented a lot of the biggest tragedies like
preventing the snap like in his universe what
if they beat their version of thanos before he
could snap everyone but in order to do that this
superior version of iron man had to do really
shady things himself way more hardcore stuff
that's why he'd wind up becoming a member of
this multiverse illuminati team because that's
the vibe that they all had in the comics making
hard morally great choices is exactly what the
illuminati were built to do like the main versions
of the team even used the infinity stones during
the time runs out incursions avengers storyline to
destroy other versions of earth destroying entire
other universes to save their earth their own 616
universe which is something that mcu iron man mcu
captain america would never do remember captain
america's famous comment they do not trade lives
well the illuminati they trade lives all the time
so superior iron man in doctor strange 2 is just
like that he trades lives big time my early theory
right now just based on all the footage that we're
seeing in the trailer of this scarlet witch
tearing through their base like it's tissue
paper and all these other members of the team is
that she'll wind up killing some of the multiverse
illuminati and the reason why they're hyping them
up so much is probably so that when she does kill
some of them it'll just hit you way harder in
the theater when you're all watching it go down
like the whole thing in one division is that
they were trying to hype up that she was this
crazy powerful being her chaos magic just elevated
her to this level you've never seen before agatha
harkness even says that she's supposed to be
more powerful than the source of supreme so if
you want scarlet witch or scarlet witch's variant
to feel like a badass you just have to put them
up against way more op people and that's probably
why they're hyping up this multiverse illuminati
team as being so powerful there are some rumors
that superior iron man in the movie has a couple
infinity stones in his universe even though marvel
has been playing it fast and loose with how the
infinity stones are meant to work in the comics
infinity stones are only supposed to work in their
original universe outside of it they're no better
than paperweights like during the loki series
we actually get a lot of those some
of the guys use them as paper weights
but during the what if series they actually
changed that the infinity ultron was using his
infinity stones across many different universes
so we'll see how they treat that during doctor
strange 2 they might be playing it fast and loose
with them again in the name of big wtf moments
and they could always bend the rules a little
by saying that this illuminati base exists in
its own little pocket dimension where the rules
of reality are a little different making crazier
things possible i also like the theory that
the illuminati team themselves will be kind
of an antagonist in the movie just to make
scarlet witch feel like less of a villain
and as for who's actually playing that superior
iron man character the other actor i don't think
that it's tom cruise i'd be like blown away if it
is tom cruise but all the leaks that people are
talking about seem like they're fake photoshops
and not in like the funny andrew garfield way
where it's like oh it's clearly not a photoshop
and the actor is just saying that it's a photoshop
i've got a couple other videos about some
of the other multiverse characters that
i'm working on if you have any big requests for
the movie just write them below in the comments
big reminder that my marvel moon knight
episodes will be starting in a couple weeks too
everyone click here for that brand new
spider-man no way home toby mcguire andrew
garfield matt murdock daredevil video
that sony just released it's hilarious
and click here for my full doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one you!